[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدينا معكم ميسون نواه
واقدم لكم اخبار الساعه نبدا كالعاده
بابرز العناوين
نتنياهو يؤجل التعديلات القضائيه والشارع
يجيب سنستمر بالاحتجاج ولن نسمح بمراوغات
ديكتاتوريه
بهدف السيطره على الطرق الامداد في الشرق
الاوكراني القوات الروسيه تبدا هجوما على
مدينه افديفيكا
بغياب التيار الصدري واعتراض المستقلين
البرلمان العراقي يمرر تعديلات قانون
الانتخابات
واضرابات بريه وجويه ومائيه تشل حركه
النقل العام في المانيا والنقابات تدعو
لزياده الاجور تماشيا مع التضخم
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير واهلا بكم طبعا الى اخبار
الساعه لهذه الليله والتي كما ذكرت نخصص
معظمها لتغطيه التطورات في اسرائيل والتي
ترقد هذه الايام على صفيح ساخن ما هو
السبب سعي الائتلاف الحكومي اليمني لادخال
تعديلات قضائيه تتيح لمجلس النواب الذي
يسيطر عليه ائتلاف نتنياهو ان يتحكم
بالقرارات التي كانت من اختصاص المحكمه
العليا هذه التعديلات التي اجججت موجه غضب
عارف في الشارع الاسرائيلي وصل ذروتها مع
اعلان نتنياهو اقاله وزير الدفاع
الرافد للتعديلات الشارع نجح في احداث
تصدعات في جسد ائتلاف نتنياهو الحكومي
وحتى داخل حزبه الليكود
من خلال
سنعطي فرصه لتمرير التعديلات القضائيه عبر
اجماع واسع لذا قررت تاجيل التعديلات
القضائيه لهذه الدوره من الكنيست حتى نصل
لاجماع لدينا اغلبيه في الكنيست تجعلنا
نناقش التعديلات القضائيه وستتم مناقشه
التعديلات القضائيه في الدوره القادمه من
الكنيست اود الاشاره الى اني حصلت على
موافقه اغلبيه زملائي في الحكومه لمنع
الحرب الاهليه عبر الحوار هذه الازمه
تجبرنا على التصرف بمسؤوليه
اعلان نتنياهو عن تاجيل التعديلات
القضائيه لم يقنع الشارع الاسرائيلي حيث
اكد قادته عزمهم الاستمرار بالاحتياجات
معتبرين ان تاجيل التعديلات مناوره من
رئيس الحكومه لاعاده فرط الديكتاتوريه
لاحقا اما من وجهه نظر نتنياهو فبقائهم في
الشارع يعني حربا اهليا لن تقبل حكومته
بها واصفا المحتجين بالاقليه المتطرفه
التي تريد تمزيق اسرائيل داعيا قاده الجيش
الى مواجهه العصيان
هناك اقليه متطرفه تريد تمزيق اسرائيل
وتسحبنا لحرب اهليه نحن على مسار صدام في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ولن نقبل بحرب اهليه
لا اقبل نداءات العصيان واطالب قياده
الجيش والاجهزه الامنيه ان يقفوا في وجه
حركه العصيان اطالب قاده الجيش بمواجهه
ظاهره رفض الخدمه العسكريه الجيش
الاسرائيلي لا يمكن ان يقبل برفض الخدمه
العسكريه من القدس ينضم الى دكتور ميرسي
واستاذ العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
العبريه دكتور مصري اهلا بكم الشارعين منذ
لحظات كنا نتابع ان المحتجين ما زالوا على
الطرقات وكان هناك ايضا كانوا يواجهون
بخراطيم المياه هل هذا مؤشر بانه هذا
التعليق لموضوع التعديلات والاصلاحات كما
يسميها نتانياهو لن يجدي نفعا
شكرا لكم على الاستضافه الكريمه هو طبعا
نتنيه اتخذ القرار المناسب ولكن ربما في
الوقت غير المناسب حيث انه الوقت تاخر
كثيرا الصدام اليوم لم يعد مع الشارع
وانما اصبح مع المؤسسات انا استاذ جمال
العبريه في وسائل القدس كما ذكرتم جمال
العبريه كما كل الجماعات الحكوميه في
اسرائيل في ادراك منذ الصباح تضامنا مع
الشارع وكذلك مؤسسات اخرى في الدوله اذا
المساله خرجت عن اطار الازمه السياسيه
خرجت عن الاطار الازمه السياسيه
ماذا استوقفكم فيه كيف يمكن ان يبنى على
هذا الخطاب دكتور مصري
محاوله للهروب الى الامام محاوله ليعمل
على تفويت اللحظه ولكن انا اعتقد انه هذا
غير مجدي يجب وقف هذه الاجراءات تماما
والعدول تماما عن المسار ولا اعتراف
بالشرعيه
وسلطه المحكمه العليا والذهاب الى حوار
جاد مع المعارضه في اطار مبادره الرئيس
ليس كل شيء سيء في هذه
المشاريع التعديلات الدستوريه هناك اشياء
مقبوله ولكن هناك اشياء غير مقبوله على
الاطلاق وبالتالي يجب الاعاده الصياغه وان
يكون هناك حد ادنى من الاجماع الاجماع
الوطني
هل لاحظتم بانه من الممكن ان يكون هناك
جديه هذه المره من قبل نتنياهو وحكومته
للذهاب للحوار بشكل جدي لقبول ايضا بعض
التعديلات او بعض الافكار التي يريدها
الشارع وتريدها المعارضه
من الصعب لانه ان فعل ذلك فسوف تسقط
الحكومه هناك عناصر داخل الائتلاف هذا هو
مشروع هذا هو مشروع مشروعهم هم دخلوا لهذا
الائتلاف بهدف
تغيير النظام القائم تغيير النظام القائم
واقصاء القضاء
وان يمرروا قوانين هي طبعا قوانين لا
علاقه لها على الاطلاق بالاعراف المتابعه
في اسرائيل وهويه اسرائيل كدوله ديمقراطيه
ويهوديه وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه الحكم
ولكن الاخطر من ذلك هو ليس الانقسام داخل
الائتلاف لانه من الممكن ان يعوض نتنياهو
خروج احد الاحزاب المتطرفه بادخال حزب من
احزاب الوسط ولكن الاكثر من ذلك هو
الانقسام داخل الحسبه
وهذه الخطوره حتى بالنسبه للمستقبل
السياسي لساني لانه مهيمن تماما على
الليكود وهذه هي هو هو عنصر القوه لديه
يعني ما يميز نتنياه عن كل رؤساء وزراء
السابقين الذين اتهموا الته مه اتهموا
بالفساد سواء برئوا فيما بعد كالراحه
هو ان جميعهم
لفظوا من احزابهم
ما الجدوى من هذا الوقت من هذه الاشهر
الاربعه المقبله اذا كانت الامور ستبقى
على ما هي وليس هناك من ثقه بان هذه
الحكومه ونيتانيا وهذا الائتلاف هو قادر
على احداث اي تغيير
انا اعتقد انه هو الرهان من انه هذا سوف
يقلل من زخم المظاهرات
الحشد ولك انا انا يعني لا اعتقد ان هناك
ما سوف يعني لهذا لا يقنع الشارع هذا لا
يكفي لان ليس هناك ثقه العلاج وهذه نقطه
هامه للغايه ان نتذكر بانه او ان ندرك
بانها المساله كلمه ليست معلقه فقط
بمشروع الاصطلاح القضائي هناك خلفيه ما هي
الخلفيه الخلفيه هناك رئيس وزراء في
السلطه منذ سته عشر سنه صحيح ليس بشكل
متواصل ولكن فتره طويله ومتهم بالفساد
متهم بالفساد ولديه وزراء متهمين كذلك
بالفساد ويحكم مع احزاب
اخترع ان يحكم مع احزاب غايه في التطرف
ولديها مشاريع طبعا قسم كبير من الشعب
اسرائيل
الديمقراطي ليبرالي لا يقبل على اطلاق
بهذا التوجه هو يخشى حقيقه من تنامي هذه
القوى في داخل الاسلام
المعارضه مثلا لابيد كانت ايضا
ابدوا بعض الايجابيه اتجاه هذا التاجيل
وبعض الايجابيه اتجاه حوار ممكن مع
نتنياهو وحكومته
لانه هذا هو الحد الادنى ولكن هذا لا يكفي
هذا لا يكفي وانا
استمعت الى ما قاله السيد لبيد واخرين لا
شك في انه
المطلب اليوم هو وقف هذه الاجراءاتا
هو الاحتكام الى الشرعيه طب اذا يعني
اسرائيل على على ما هو المشهد المتوقع في
الايام المقبله اذا كان الشارع غير مقتنع
وهو يريد
ايقاف هذه التعديلات وليس تاجيلها وفي حال
وجود عدم الثقه نتنياهو وحكومته
يعني دعايه نتحدث بصراحه انا اعتقد انه
سوف تكون الاشهر القادمه
تمر في جو من القلاقل وفي نهايه المطاف لن
تصمت طويلا هذه الحكومه لن تصمت طويلا
لانه هناك عناصر تهدد بالانسحاب من
الائتلاف هناك انشقاقات داخل حزب الليكود
ليس فقط نواب كنيسه ولكن كذلك اليوم هناك
وزراء يؤيدون خطوه الوزير الدفاع المقال
وبالتالي انا اعتقد بانه من الصعب ان
تستمرها يستمر هذا الائتلاف باربعه وستين
مقعد في الاشهر القديمه
عجان ام اجلا سوف ترينا
الراي اليوم ايضا بعض الاستطلاعات تتحدث
بانه هناك خساره لهذا الائتلاف لبعض
المقاعد حسب استطلاعات الراي اشكرك دكتور
نائر مصري استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
الجامعه العبريه على المشاركه معنا
منذ الرابع من يناير الماضي لن تتوقف
توترات في اسرائيل ازمه سياسيه وقضائيه
اطاحت بحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو تدفق الاف
الاسرائيليين الى الشوارع وسط تل ابيب
للاعتراض على مشروع قانون التعديلات
القضائيه حيث وقعت اشتباكات بين عدد من
المحتجين وقوات الامن لكن مشاهدينا ما هو
هذا المشروع الذي اججج اسرائيل غضبا اولا
المشروع ينص على ادخال تغييرات جذريه على
النظام القضائي هذه التغييرات من شانها
الحد ومن سلطات المحكمه العليا وتمنح
النواب سلطه اكبر في تعيين القضاه الذي
يتطلب حاليا موافقه السياسيين والقضاه
اعضاء اللجنه المعنيه ومن ابرز التغييرات
التي يقترحها المشروع هو بندو الاستثناء
الذي يتيح للنواب البرلمان باغلبيه بسيطه
الغاء قرار صادر عن المحكمه العليا طبعا
السائد في اسرائيل التي ليس لديها دستور
ان من صلاحيات المحكمه العليا الغاء
قوانين يقرها الكنيسه اذا اعتبرت انها
تتعارض مع القوانين الاساسيه للبلاد وهكذا
فان اقرار بند الاستثناء هذا من شانه
السماح للبرلمان باعاده وضع قانون رفضه
القضاه موضع تطبيق
من القدس ينضم الى مدير مكتب العربيه زياد
حلبي زياد اهلا بك معنا التطورات الان كنا
منذ قليل نتابع بان المحتجين يواجهون
بخراطيم المياه هل نتوقع بان هذه
الاحتياجات ستستمر الغد وفي الايام
المقبله
الامر يبدو كذلك ميسون بهذا المعنى الرد
على كلام نتنياهو في الشارع كان عمليا بان
المظاهرات والاحتجاجات مستمره ما شوهد من
استخدام خراطيم المياه العادمه والقاء
قنابل صوتيه كان في شارع كابلا في تل ابيب
حيث تتواصل الاحتجاجات والاشتباكات بين
الشرطه الاسرائيليه والمحتجين لانهم
يحاولون هذه الليله ايضا اغلاق خطوط السير
الرئيسيه المسماه ايلون كما فعلوا الليله
الماضيه على مدى 11 ساعه فعلوا ذلك الشرطه
تحاول ان تمنعهم من الوصول الى هناك مجددا
على المقلب الاخر في القدس الغربي ايضا
كانت تطورات بارزه بعد انتهاء التظاهر
الكبير
للمحتجين ضد نتنياهو والحكومه عمليا كان
هناك تظاهره ايضا كبيره من عشرات الالاف
لليمين في نهايه هذه المظاهره وصل وصل
مجموعه تسمى لافاميليا هي مجموعه متطرفه
وعنصريه جدا
وحاولت الاعتداء ونجحت في الاعتداء على من
تبقى من المتظاهرين ضد الحكومه واشتبكت
بعد ذلك مع الشرطه
الاسرائيليه
القيمون القائمون على المظاهرات اعلنوا
بانها ستستمر يوم السبت ستكون هناك مظاهره
حاشده ايضا في تل ابيب طب زياد بالنسبه
للشلل العام في اسرائيل يعني كان من
المعروف بان هذا الاسبوع هو شلل عام في
اسرائيل هل صدرت اي معلومات بخلاف ذلك
يعني لوقف الاضرابات لوقف هذا الشلل وماذا
عن مصير جالانت
بالنسبه للاضراب الذي اعلن من النقبات
المهنيه
ونقابه العمال في اسرائيل تم تعليقه بعد
ان علق نتنياهو الخطه عمليا سنرى غدا وبعد
غد ان كان المحتجون سيواصلون البرنامج على
كما هو ام سيكتفون بالتظاهر الرئيسي كل
يوم سبت
محاولات الشلل كل يوم خميس كما فعلوا على
مدى اثني عشر اسبوع
انقضت
وهذا سنراه في الايام المقبله لكن بدون
ادنى شك بان عمليا اليوم هناك يرتسم مشهد
يعني فيه مفارقه في اسرائيل الاغلبيه
البرلمانيه الممثله بالحكومه والائتلاف في
مواجهه الاغلبيه الشعبيه في الشارع اليوم
استطلاعات الراي اكدت ما نقوله طوال هذه
الفتره بان اكثر من 60% من الاسرائيليين
يرفضون خطه نتنياهو لا القضاء وحتى داخل
حزب الليكود اغلبيه واضحه تؤيد وقف
التشريعات المتصله بهذا الموضوع وشعبيه
نتنياه انهارت على نحو كبير اليوم حتى ان
جانسي يفوقه الان في اكثر ملائمه للحكومه
والائتلاف برئاسه
يتراجع الى 53 نائبا في مقابل 61 للمعارضه
لاول مره وكل ذلك فقط بعد ثلاثه اشهر من
تشكيل هذه الحكومه شكرا لك من القدس مدير
مكتب العربيه زياد حلبي
مستمرون معكم ولكن بعد فاصل قصير ابقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم افادت السلطات بمدينه ناشف
بولايه تنس الامريكيه بمقتل سبعه اشخاص في
حادثه اطلاق نار في ولايه تينيسيا
الامريكيه كما ذكرنا وقلد السلطات ان
ثلاثه اطفال بين القتلى اضافه الى ثلاثه
من البالغين كما تم قتل منفذه الهجوم وهي
امراه تبلغ من العمر 28 عاما الى ذلك طالب
البيت الابيض الحزب الجمهوري بمساعدته لسن
تشريع يمنع حمل الاسلحه الرشاشه
[موسيقى]
الى الملف الاوكراني رغم مروري ثمانيه
اشهر من المواجهات الدمويه في بخموت
المواجهه تحولت الى حرب استنزاف وجانب
الصراع كل منهما يريد حسم المعركه للصادقه
لكن مشاهد دمار في مدينه الواقعه على
مسافه 13 كيلومترا فقط عن دانياسك والتي
تشهد قصفا مدفعيا مكثفا بات اشبه بصور من
فيلم سينمائي عن نهايه العالم السيطره
عليها تتيح للجيش الروسي قطع خط امداد
القوات الاوكرانيه في الشرق وسيسمح لموسكو
باحكام قبضتها في جنوب شرق اوكرانيا وضمان
تامين خطوط امداد لوجستيه للجيش ومع
اشتداد المعارك السلطات الاوكرانيه بدات
في سحب موظفي البلديه من المدينه كما
يحاول الجيش الاوكراني تمسك بمواقعه
الحاليه اما في اخر التطورات العسكريه
ايضا عادت اطقم العسكريه اوكرانيه الى
بلادها بعد ان انهت في بريطانيا
لاستخدام دبابات قتاليه من طراز تشالنجر 2
وبحسب صحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه يرتقب ان
تصل الدبابات وطواقم الاوكرانيه المدربه
الى مواقعها في الوقت المناسب بالتزامن مع
تواصل الاستعدادات للهجوم المضاده التي
تخطط له اما في الداخل الروسي قصص من
الصعب عددها على كثرتها لمواطنين روس
نجحوا في الفرار من الاقامه الجبريه
المفروضه عليهم اذ سردت صحيفه واشنطن بوست
تفاصيله هروب بعض السياسيين والنشطاء
الروس الذين يرتدون سوارا الكترونيا على
الكاحل وضعتها دائره السجون الفيدراليه
الروسيه عقب معارضتهم للحرب في اوكرانيا
وبحسب الصحيفه الامريكيه فان هؤلاء
الفارين استخدموا تكتيكات مختلفه واساليب
مراوغه بارعه للخروج وعبور حدود روسيا
باتجاه دول امنه اذا عبرت شابه روسيه الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي متنكره في زي متسوله بلا
ماوى
حيث بدلت السيارات في طريقها ثلاث مرات
وعبرت نقطه حدوديه رسميه حتى وصلت الى
ليتوانيا
ووفقا لتقرير واش يحصل العديد من النشطاء
الذين يرغبون بالفرار على المساعده من
مجموعات روسيه سريه وجماعات حقوقيه خارجيه
يؤمنون تاشيرات انسانيه لهم
يضل استمرار التوترات بين روسيا والغرب
اتهم السكرتير مجلس الامن القوميه الروسي
نيكولاي بتروشيف دول الناتو بانها باتت
طرفا اساسيا في الحرب الاوكرانيه وان
هدفها الرئيسي يتمثل بهزيمه روسيا
وتقسيمها
لا يزال خط الغاز نورد ستريم اللذان
يربطان روسيا بالمانيا في صلب التوترات
الجيو السياسيه مع استمرار التحقيقات بشان
تفجيرهما فبعد تلميحات استخباراتيه غربيه
وقضائيه المانيه سابقه الى احتمال تورط
مجموعات اوكرانيه بالتفجير كشف تقرير
بريطاني جديد قد لا يصب في صالح روسيا عن
تحقيقات تتحدث عن ان قافل مؤلفه من ست سفن
تابعه للبحريه الروسيه تواجدت حول موقع
تخريب خط انابيب نورث ستريم قبل خمسه ايام
الوقوعه واضافت انه تم تعطيل ثلاث من
القنوات الاربعه التي تحمل الغاز الطبيعي
من روسيا الى المانيا على طول قاعد بحر
البلطيق وبسبب انفجارات بالقرب من جزيره
بورن هالم دنماركيه يوم السادس والعشرين
من سبتمبر العام الماضي وفقا لصحيفه
[موسيقى]
تحتضن المدينه المنوره المعرضه والمتحف
الدولي للسيره النبويه الذي يعنى بالتعريف
الشامل لسيره النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
الزميل سلطان السلمي ياخذنا في جوله
لنتعرف اكثر على هذا المعرض ضمن سلسله من
الحرمين
[موسيقى]
300 باحث من مختلف الدول الاسلاميه
قطو 17 عاما من البحث والتوثيق وجمع
المصادر العلميه الموثوقه لكتابه المحتوى
الخاص لسيره المصطفى وهجرته والاحداث التي
مرت عليه في معرض السيره النبويه
والحضاره الاسلاميه في المدينه المنوره
كما نشاهد نلاحظ من خلال هذا المتحف عده
اقسام من اهمها قسم الله عز وجل اهل
الثناء والمجد كل ما يتعلق عن الله عز وجل
واسمائه وصفاته ثم قسم الانبياء وكانك
تراهم ثم قسم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وكانك تراه من خلال ادابه ثم النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم وكانك معه في مكه والمدينه
ثم قسم المراه
الطفل في الاسلام ثم بعد ذلك ياتيك المتحف
والتقنيات المعاصره الموجوده في هذا
المعرض [__] المعرض مجسمات تقدم وصفا
مرئيا لطريقه هجره النبي من مكه الى
المدينه وابرز المواقع التي مر بها
والاحداث التي صاحبت هجرته ويتيح لزائري
مشاهده مجسمات تقريبيه صممت بشكل وصفي
لتجسده الطبيعه العمرانيه
والمعالم الطبيعيه للمدينتين في عهد النبي
المعرض راعي جميع فئات المجتمع جميع
الاديان جميع الاعمار كذلك سواء الرجال او
نساء مسلمين وغير المسلمين كذلك اهتم
المتحف بالماده العلميه المجموعه والمحكمه
والمفارسه عبر احدث التقنيات واحدث العلوم
يحتوي المعرض على وسائل عرض متطوره وحديث
ه لعرض الحقائق والمعلومات المتعلقه بسنه
وسيره النبي محمد وتقديمها للزوار من خلال
اليات مبتكره في البرمجه والهيكله
والتبويب والتصنيف بطرق عرض عصريه متعدده
من المدينه المنوره سلطان السلمي العربيه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم اليه سلطان السلمي
مراس العربيه سلطان اهلا بك معنا الاجواء
لديك الان ودعنا نتحدث اكثر عن كيفيه
اداره الحشود بعد صلوات بعد صلاه التراويح
اهلا بك مشروع اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل بعد انتهاء صلاه العشاء
والتراويح هنا بالحرم المكي قبل اقل من
ساعه من الان بدات عمليات الخروج من
المسجد الحرام من المعتمرين والمصلين
للتوجه الى محطات النقل التي تقوم بعمليات
نقلهم الى محطات الخاصه بمركباتهم او حتى
المحطات المجاوره لمساكنهم نتحدث اليوم
نتواجد حاليا في هذه احدى ساحات الحرم
المكي وتحديدا امام باب الملك عبد العزيز
لنشاهد عمليات خروج المعتمرين بشكل تنظيمي
وعمليات اداره حشود تم العمل عليها منذ
وقت سابق للتاكد من ضمان عمليات خروج
المعتمرين والمصلين
بكل سلاسه وكل انسيابيه كبيره لاسيه من
الحرم المكي يشهد هذا العام وهذا الشهر
تحديدا في رمضان اعداد كبيره سجل الحرم
حتى الان اكثر من ثلاثه مليون معتمر ومصلي
زاروا الحرم منذ بدء شهر رمضان لذلك عملت
القطاعات
ورئاسه الشؤون الحرمين وكذلك كافه
القطاعات العامله هنا بالمسجد الحرام لضبط
عمليات اداره الحشود للتاكد من سلامه
المعتمرين اثناء عمليات دخولهم او حتى
خروجهم داخل الحرم المكي تم تخصيص 14 مسار
منها سبعه للخروج وكذلك سبعه للدخول كما
نشاهد الان هنالك مسار للدخول وكذلك مسار
للخروج يشاهد الان كما امامكم الكاميرا
هذا المسار هو مخصص للدخول اما المسار
الاخر من وتحديدا من باب الجياد اسماعيل
هي مسارات مخصصه لخروج المعتمرين هذه
التنظيمات او هذه المسارات تساهم بشكل
كبير في انسيابيه وجود او انسيابيه الحركه
داخل الحرم المكي كذلك بعد خروجه من الحرم
المكي هنالك مسارات خصصتها المديريه
العامه للمرور فقط للمشاه ليستطيع المعتمر
او المصلي وصول ان يصل الى محطه الحافلات
التي تقع بالقرب من الحرم المكي
بس يعني ركوب الحافله والذهاب الى او
التوجه الى محطه نقل الحافلات وهي محطه
مخصصه وعددها خمس محطات رئيسيه تقوم بنقل
المعتمرين من والى الحرم المكياهد
القطاعات الامنيه تتواجد بشكل مكثف منذ
ساعات الصباح الاولى كل يوم من شهر رمضان
لضبط العمليات التنظيميه لدخول وخروج
المعتمرين وتزداد اعداد القوات الامنيه
وتحديدا منذ ساعات المساء الاولى وتحديدا
بعد صلاه العصر وحتى الساعه الثانيه عشر
هنالك قطاعات امنيه تتواجد بشكل كبير
ممثله في قوات الطوارئ وكذلك المرور وايضا
قطاع الدفاع المدني وغيرها من قطاعات
المسانده التي تعمل على مساعده او تنظيم
حركه اداره الحشود في الحرم المكي كذلك
مما يساعد في عمليات تسهيل خروج دخول
المعتمرين وجود اكثر من ثمانيه الاف متطوع
يقومون بمساعده كبار السن وذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه عبر مسارات كذلك
قصصتها رئاسه الشؤون الحرمين لايصال
المعتمرين خارج الحرم المكي وركوب هذه
الحافلات المهيئه والمجهزه لذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه كذلك وجود الفرقه
التطوعيه الاخرى الميدانيه الطبيه في
ساحات المسجد الحرام في حال سقوط احد
المعتمرين او المصلين او اصابه بجروح يتم
علاجه فورا داخل هذه الساحات الان نشاهد
عمليات خروجهم انه متوقع من خلال الساعه
القادمه ان تخف الاعداد ومن ثم تعود بالزي
او تعود تزداد الاعداد مع ساعات الفجر
الاولى لاداء مناسك العمره شكرا لك
المكرمه سلطان السلمي مراسل العربيه على
كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
بعد اشد وجذب استمر عده اسابيع صوت
البرلمان العراقي على تعديل قانون
الانتخابات باغلبيات مريحه وسط تلويح
القوى الرافضه باللجوء الى الشارع
يدخلون العسكر هذا خلال بالنظام في جلسه
عاصفه استمرت حتى الفجر شهدت اعتراض
وانسحاب الكتل البرلمانيه المستقله صوت
البرلمان العراقي على تعديل قانون
الانتخابات تعديل وصفته القوى المعارضه
بانه تكريس لسيطره الاحزاب الكبيره على
الدوره المقبله للبرلمان وتغييب للتيارات
الديمقراطيه المستقله تمرير قانون مرفوض
حقيقه من قبل الشعب ومن قبل المرجعيه هو
تمرد على الشعب حقيقه من صوت على سانتيجو
ستكون بدايه النهايه له اذا الشعب يوما
اراد الحياه فلابد ان يستجيب القدر هنا
قدرنا ان نذهب معارضه وطنيه واعيه حقيقيه
ما هي ابرز التعديلات التي اجريت على
قانون الانتخابات العوده الى قانون 2018
الذي رفضته حركه تشرين الاحتجاجيه عام
2019 كل محافظه ستعد دائره انتخابيه واحده
اي 18 دائره بدلا من 83 دائره التي اعتمدت
في الانتخابات الاخيره التعديلات الجديده
تصب في صالح القوى السياسيه الكبيره ولا
تمنح المستقلين فرصه في المنافسه اعاده
تحديث سجل الناخبين في كركوك بعد تسويه
بين قومياتها العربيه والتركمانيه
والكرديه اعاده العمل بالعد والفرز اليدوي
تعديل قانون الانتخابات والتصويت عليه
بهذه الصيغه ما كان ليتم لولا وجود اتفاق
بين القوى السياسيه الشيعيه والسنيه
والكرديه
حينما استقرت كل هذه الفتره
واحكمت قبضتها على المشهد السياسي لم تكن
من فراغ بالاتت من اتفاق سياسي اداء لا
تكوين ائتلاف اداره الدوله بالتالي تكوين
الحكومه وهذا هو ما ادى اليوم الى نيمار
القرن بهذه الاريحيه بغياب التيار الصدري
وربما معارضه الاحزاب المستقله والصغيره
اقر البرلمان العراقي تعديل قانون
الانتخابات الذي ستجرى بموج به الانتخابات
المحليه المتوقعه في نوفمبر المقبل من
بغداد منتظر رشيد العربيه
[موسيقى]
توقفت حركه النقل البري والجوي والمائي
بشكل كامل في المانيا في يوم اضراب دعت
اليه نقبات عماليه للضغط على مشغل
القطارات والمطار لزياده رواتب الموظفين
وحذرت النقابات من ان يوم الاضراب كان
تحذيريه وان اضرابات اخرى ستاليه في حال
لم يتم التواصل الاتفاق لتقديم الزيادات
التي تتماشى مع تضخم المرتفع في البلاد
ما زالت الادراج الكهربائيه في محطه برلين
الرئيسيه للقطارات تعمل رغم انها توصلنا
وتوصل المسافرين هنا الى منصه قطارات
فارغه لا تتوقف فيها القطارات ولا تغادرها
وكان الساعه تتوقفت هنا
اطفي اط لوحه اعلاناتي توقيت القطارات
وغاب المسافرون الذين يقصدون هذه المحطه
عاده للسفر الى مختلف المدن الالمانيه
والاوروبيه فالاضراب الذي دعت اليه
نقابتان عماليتان في المانيا تمثلان قرابه
الثلاثه ملايين موظف شلح حركه القطارات
والطيران في معظم المدن الالمانيه وتحرك
بالقطارات بات مستحيلا وفرض على الكثيرين
تغيير خطط سفرهم
من جهتنا الامر مقبول ولكن من جهه اخرى لا
اجد الامر جيدا علينا ان نبحث عن فندق
جديد لاننا غادرنا فندقنا اليوم وايضا
الان علينا استبدال بطاقه القطار التي كنا
اشتريناها للسفر اليوم
نحن هنا اليوم لانه عيد ميلادي واردنا
زياره بوتساب فانا هنا للسياحه وجئنا بحثا
عن قطار ولكن لم نتمكن من اللحاق به
وعلينا الان ان نجد وسيله بديله ولكن
الموظفين المضربين لديهم اسبابهم للاضراب
مسافرون فرنسيون كانوا اكثر تفهما لحركه
الاضراب هذه التي اراد منظمها ان تحاكي
التحركات في فرنسا اجد ان مطالبه مبرره
لتغطيه التضخم واؤيد الموظفين رغم معرفه
بان هذا يؤثر على المسافرين ولكن لو كان
هذا الحل لكي يحصل على مبتغاهم انا اؤيدهم
النقابات العمليه تطالب بزياده رواتب
موظفي سكك الحديد والمطارات بنسبه تتراوح
بين 10 ونصف بالمئه واثني عشره بالمئه لكي
تعوض عن التضخم الذي زادت نسبته على 9%
الشهر الماضي وهي تحذر من ان الشلل الذي
اصيبت به البلاد هذا اليوم ليس الا
البدايه في حال لم يتم التواصل لاتفاقا
حول زياده الاجور راغده العربيه برلين
[موسيقى]
تداعيات التوقيتين في لبنان السياسيه
والطائفيه دفعت رئيس الحكومه نجيب ميقاتي
الى التراجع عن قراره بالابقاء على
التوقيت الشتوي واعلن الانتقال الى
التوقيت الصيفي ليله الاربعاء الخميس وحتى
تعديله يعيش اللبنانيون ضياعا في امورهم
اليوميه
بين التوقيتين في لبنان ضاعت مواعيد
واختلطت اخرى وامتزجت المشاعر بين الغضب
والسخريه من ازمه عقارب ساعه تحدث العالم
بغرابتها
ناجي واحد من الشباب اللبناني الغاضب من
سلطه افتعال الازمات التي لا تؤثر الا على
شعبها
لان الصراحه اثر علي كثير شكل الكثير يعني
مؤذي اذا بدك يعني انا كنت هلا مفروض حكيم
اسنانكم من ساعه انا هلا فليت من الشغل
راح علي الموعد صار لي اسبوعين بس بركض
ورا هالموعد ليظبطوا ولهلا لزبط من ورا
هالتوقيت رحله موعد الحكيم
على اي توقيت انت سؤال يرافق اللبنانيين
في خطواتهم اليوميه كما حصل في بدايه ازمه
الدولار وانتشار مواقع والتطبيقات تنشر
اسعار الصرف المختلفه بات للتوقيت في
لبنان موقع ايضا قديش الساعه هو احد هذه
المواقع وعندما ندخل نرى هذين التوقيتين
انترناشونال تايم ان بيروت اي التوقيت
العالمي في بيروت وبي ام تي اي بالريميقات
تايم وفي البدايه هناك اشاره وبطريقه
فكاهيه الى ان هذا التوقيت هو حسب سوق
التوقيت بدل السوق السوداء
حالات الضياع سحبت على المؤسسات والمدارس
والمصارف بين من بقي على التوقيت الشتوي
ومن غيره الى الصيفي على انعم مدرسه تيتو
وايت الجديد يعني الصيفه الشرعي ولاده
الشتوي فبكره بالعاده انا ولادي من البيت
فبكره انا رح فلن يعني ما ضايعه مش عارفين
كيف بدنا نمشي
استغلت ازمه التوقيت لتصفيه الحسابات
السياسيه ونبشت قبور الطائفيه ما دفع
برئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجيب ميقاتي
وبعد اجتماع الحكومه الى اعلان العوده الى
التوقيت الصيفي ليلى الاربعاء الخميس بعد
معالجه الامور التقنيه ناهد يوسف العربيه
فيروز
ختاما نذكر بعناوين اخبار الساعه
يؤاجر تعديلات القضائيه والشارع يجيب
سنستمر بالاحتجاج ولن نسمح بمراوغات
ديكتاتوريه
[تصفيق]
بهدف السيطره على الطرق الامداد في الشرق
الاوكراني القوات الروسيه تبدا هجوما على
مدينه
بغياب التيار الصدري واعتراض المستقلين
البرلمان العراقي يمرر التعديلات قانون
الانتخابات
[تصفيق]
اضرابات بريه وجويه ومائيه تشل حركه النقل
العام في المانيا والنقابات تدعو لزياده
الاجور تماشيا مع التضخم اشكر لكم في
المتابعه اترككم في امان الله
[موسيقى]